TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So we're now in the
Android Sandbox area.
I'm going to spend
some time in this area
because there's a lot going on.
But we're going to start
with just features of the OS.
And David here is going
to tell us about a couple
of things I've been
really curious about.
Can we start with Kotlin?
Let's talk about Kotlin.
DAVID: Sure.
Kotlin is definitely
the show-stealer,
it seems to me from
watching the keynotes.
So Android Studio now
has Kotlin support.
You can create a new project.
And you'll see that
you have the ability
to check Kotlin support
in from the beginning.
We already have a
Kotlin app here,
but you can also write
Java code and convert
it to Kotlin very simply.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And do
you like writing Kotlin?
DAVID: I love writing Kotlin.
I actually haven't
gotten a chance
to write Kotlin recently.
But when it was--
when I was first learning
about it a year ago,
I spent a lot of time just
going through the language
and getting very
excited about it,
just because it looked
so much more concise,
and it brings in a
lot of modern features
that I like from a lot
of other languages.
And I was really happy to see
how fast they moved on it,
and the great tooling
support that IntelliJ
brought into it as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
I mean, I've been talking to
people around the festival
today, and one of the
things they keep saying
is how well-designed
they believe Kotlin is
and what a mature language
it is because of that.
DAVID: Yeah, no,
it's absolutely.
I feel that they've
got a lot of influences
from a lot of new languages.
I highly recommend trying
it out, give it a shot.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
Katherine, you've
been working on bringing
Kotlin into Android
for a little while.
Can you tell us what the
motivation for that was?
KATHERINE: Yeah.
So I think the big reasons we
want to bring Kotlin to Android
were that, like David
says, most developers who
try it find it to be really
concise and expressive,
and has a lot of awesome
features like type
and null safety, which are
really useful for writing
stable, non-crashy apps.
Plus it's totally compatible
with the existing Android
environment, and also
with the Java language,
which means that, even if you
have a large existing Android
code base, it's really easy
to incrementally adopt it.
And you can kind of try
things where it works.
You don't have to go rewriting
large swaths of the code.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's awesome, being
able to incrementally adopt
it, as you were saying,
so you don't have to sort of
jump in and refactor everything
all at once.
KATHERINE: Yeah, exactly.
Like, if you have some chunk
of Java you're happy with,
you can just leave
that, keep modifying it,
write some new module in Kotlin.
You kind of adopt it very
organically as you see fit.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
KATHERINE: Oh, and I
think the final thing is
just we've been hearing about it
from more and more developers,
that they love it,
it really makes
them happy to write in it.
And yeah, we try to
listen to our developers
and give them things
they love, so hey.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Absolutely.
I want to look at something
else as well, David--
the profiler in Android Studio.
Can you show me something there?
DAVID: Sure.
We're really excited
about the profilers.
I feel like this is
a long time coming.
If you look here,
you can actually
see that this is
displaying Bitmaps.
It's a sample Android app.
We downloaded it as is.
We didn't modify it at all.
And if you look over
here, you can actually
see we've already started
the profilers on it.
We have the CPU, memory,
and network profiler.
So if I start to
interact with the app,
you'll start to see
the different profilers
[INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, wow.
DAVID: Yeah.
So you can deep dive
into any of them.
You can sample
CPU activity here.
We can click on some stuff.
And then what you'll see is,
if you drag across there,
you could actually look at
the content of the request.
This is actually
an HTTPS request,
and you can still see
the contents of it,
which is something that
we're very excited about,
because that was normally a
challenge for a lot of people
to try to do.
I think some people would
debug in HTTP traffic
in order to see it.
And so we've sort of enabled
some new features here,
which we're happy about.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah.
I'm used to inspecting
the traffic on the machine
that I'm testing on to try and
get that debug information.
And yet, here it
is right in Studio.
That's so convenient.
DAVID: Yeah.
I really hope that people
have a chance to play with it.
We hope that they find
the profilers intuitive.
I mean, to me,
what's exciting is,
as you're messing around
with your app, you might--
all of these things that
were invisible for you,
you now have a chance to
actually play around with it
and see it.
And as I said, we
don't even think
we're including
documentation with it.
But we're even hoping
that, even without it,
you should just be able to
play around and try things
out and see what
happens, and then learn
more about your code.
We were once
debugging some code.
And we're like, no,
something's wrong here.
We're getting this
weird memory spike.
And we were actually--
we were surprised to find
that, all along, this code
had a problem with it,
but we didn't know
about it until we
had written our own profilers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's profiling.
DAVID: There you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
David, thanks so much
for taking the time.
DAVID: Thank you very much.
A few people online
have been asking
me to get a demo of
picture-in-picture.
So I found Rob, and he's
going to give that to us.
ROB: Hey, I'm Rob from the
Android Window Manager team.
And I've been working
on picture-in-picture
for this release.
We're really excited
about it because Android--
you know, it's always
been a good platform
for interacting with content,
watching YouTube, et cetera.
But if you want to start
to interact more deeply
and multitask, we haven't
always provided the tools.
And I think picture-in-picture
is a great one.
So I'll walk you through
a way of using it.
So here we have this video.
And it's a Go game by Lee
Sedol, the player who famously
challenged AlphaGo last year.
And we can see, if we go back
to Home, we'll get the video.
And it's still playing here.
We can move it around.
And for example, I
could go into my Go app,
and I could start to multitask.
And I could play
the game along--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Oh, that's so cool.
ROB: --so that I could, you
know, play along with the game
and begin to explore
my own variations.
And I can dismiss,
tap when I'm done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
ROB: That's the Android
picture-in-picture.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Rob.
ROB: Well, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Everybody's
talking about Kotlin,
so I was able to get some
more info out of Andre
from JetBrains.
Hi, Andre.
ANDRE: Hello.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So first question.
You've been working with the
Android team for a while.
What are you most excited
about with this collaboration?
ANDRE: Well, this is very great
to be here because, basically,
this means that very many
people will be coming to Kotlin,
new users, new-- well,
new, exciting ways
of using the language,
new learning materials,
new libraries, everything.
So it's-- basically, Kotlin's
growing as we are looking
at it.
And it's altogether wonderful.
I'm very grateful
to the Android team
that they had the
courage to make the move.
That was-- as they say, that
was what the public was actually
wanting them to do.
So we're very happy about it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
So let's talk a little
bit about the future
and what's coming next.
First, the language.
What's coming next with
the Kotlin language?
ANDRE: There are actually
many things we're working on.
So the brand new thing
with Kotlin is coroutines.
We have shown the
experimental design pretty--
yeah, it was, like,
three three months ago.
So coroutines are
a big thing now,
doing asynchronous
programming in an easy way.
So we're now looking into
improving that and finalizing
the design, so that the
next version of Kotlin
will probably have it
already stable so everybody
can use it and be sure it will
work for all the versions.
Then the next big thing
is multiplatform Kotlin.
So Kotlin's now big on Android,
big on the server side.
We are working on JavaScript.
And we have recently
introduced native,
which is in a technical
preview version now.
So we're trying to span the
language across many platforms
and enable multiplatform
development, where
we can, say, have a
couple of modules reused
for many platforms, and then
some platform-specific modules
implementing some functionality
in a specific way that's
leveraging the intricacies
of the platform.
So it's a very big
big direction for us.
And then there are
language-only things
like value types, for
example, for optimal storage
or collection literals.
So we have very many
directions there.
And the strategic
ones are those,
you know, platform things
and the coroutines.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
What about tooling?
What's next there?
ANDRE: Yeah.
So we're-- actually, JetBrains
is all about tooling.
So our first and
foremost goal with Kotlin
was making the
language toolable.
And now we're in a pretty
good shape with many things,
but there's a long road ahead.
We're now tightly integrated
with Android Studio,
and we'll work more on that.
So in 3.0 preview, we have new
wizards for creating things.
And we have unified analysis
for Java and Kotlin,
and we'll improve that.
We're working on
the incrementality
of the toolchain.
So Google side as well
as JetBrains side.
And for non-Android
things, we're
doing pretty much the same.
We're basically getting on par
with Java on the Java platform.
We're working on debugability
and incrementality
for JavaScript.
Native is very young for that,
but we'll get all that there,
too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
ANDRE: Thank you very much.